sur public sénat bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver sur public sénat cet
après midi les sénateurs poursuivent
l'examen du projet de loi du flou sur le
logement social
je vous rappelle que ce texte avait été
invalidé pour non respect de la
procédure parlementaire
au mois d'octobre dernier par le conseil
constitutionnel cette fois la nouvelle
version déjà adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale ne reprend pas une disposition
controversée qui avait fortement déplu
ici au groupe erds les sénateurs à
majorité radicaux de gauche et qui
obligeait les petites communes en zone
rurale de construire 10 % au moins de
logement social
ce texte devrait donc être adopté par
les sénateurs dans l'après midi pour une
application rapide dès le mois de
janvier 2013 tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle bonne après midi à
tous
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relatifs à la
mobilisation du foncier public en faveur
du logement et au renforcement des
obligations de production du logement
social dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement 50
de temps donc inséré un article
additionnel après l'article 3 un moment
52 qui est présentée par monsieur qu'à
lever jusqu'à levez vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente
alors donc lors de l'évaluation
d'intérêt en vue d'une expropriation
il est pris en compte en vertu l'article
13 15 du code de l'expropriation sa
valeur agricole où sa valeur éventuelle
si l'on considère une urbanisation
possible cependant une troisième
catégorie de nature uniquement
jurisprudentielle a été créée par la
cour de cassation dans un arrêt consorts
vigoureux contre sncf le 1er décembre
comme l'a souligné le rapport de notre
collègue jean
larcher sur la gestion des espaces
périurbains daté de 1998
il existe désormais une catégorie
intermédiaire entre la terre purement
agricoles et les surfaces totalement
urbanisables constitué par les terrains
en situation privilégiée la création
d'une catégorie supplémentaire au cas
d'expropriation a eu pour conséquence
une augmentation substantielle des prix
des terrains ainsi qualifié impactant
aussi bien l'état indemnise ateurs que
les collectivités acquéreuse potentiel
le présent amendement dont vise à
supprimer la possibilité de recourir à
une autre catégorie que celles visées à
l'article 13 15 du code de
l'expropriation afin de permettre la
réalisation d'économies par les
collectivités publiques lorsqu'elle
recours à la procédure d'expropriation
voilà alors cet amendement je leur ai
déposé je suis prêt maintenant la
ministre à le retirer s'il y a un
engagement de traiter ce sujet à
l'occasion d'un prochain texte par le
gouvernement
voilà merci chacun merci chers collègues
je vais demander l'avis des monsieur le
rapporteur spécial à porter bien bon cet
amendement vise à ce que seule la valeur
agricole où la valeur éventuelle du
terrain en cas de l'urbanisation soient
prises en compte lors de l'évaluation
d'un terrain à l'occasion d'une expo
pression il s'agit pour notre que nos
collègues me paie représenté par notre
collègue françois calvet de revenir sur
une jurisprudence de la cour de
cassation qui aurait conduit à une
augmentation substantielle des prix de
certains terrains bon à mes yeux et aux
yeux de la de la commission un tel
amendement n'a pas de lien avec le
présent projet de loi
ça me semble évident mouchard collègues
et trouverez à mes yeux davantage de
place dans le projet mme dans le
prochain projet de loi qui traitera
notamment des questions relatives à
l'urbanisme et au foncier dont j'invite
dont ses auteurs à le retirer
à défaut la commission a émis un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
mais peut-être que madame la ministre
pourrait nous dire ce qu'elle envisage
de faire dans le futur projet de loi
concernant cette proposition qui
voudraient comme je le rappelle passés
en pertes et profits
une jurisprudence de la cour de
cassation
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame le
ministre votre avis madame la présidente
je vais en profiter puisque je tiens
toujours parole monsieur le sénateur
calvet pour vous répondre sur la
question du comité régional de l'habitat
en languedoc-roussillon
ça m'a permis d'avoir l'intégralité des
des éléments donc le ch de languedoc
roussillon devait en effet se tenir hier
il a été annulé parce que le préfet
souhaitait absolument le président et
mme étaient indisponibles du fait d'une
visite ministérielle cette annulation
n'a donc absolument aucun rapport avec
le projet de loi actuellement en
discussion en discussion
le prochain crh aura donc lieu en
février
2013 et il examinera notamment la
répartition des crédits ce qui est son
fonctionnement normal
néanmoins sans attendre le prochain crh
et pour ne pas retarder l'approbation
des plh qui sont donc déjà terminé qui
devait être examinée hier le préfet a
prévu les faire examiner par le
parlement euros du crh donc les trois
plh en question très rapidement pour
qu'il puisse être approuvée ce report
n'a donc aucune incidence administratif
j'espère vous avoir totalement rassuré
pour ce qui est de l'amendement que vous
venez de présenter
vous avez eu raison le déposé parce que
il a donné lieu à un travail important
sur un plan administratif et juridique
dont je vais me permettre de vous faire
la lecture précise de l'analyse qu'ont
fait mes services de de cette question
mon cette analyse conclut à ce que votre
amendement serait dénuée de portés et
non de nature atteindre l'objectif qu'il
se fixe à savoir la disparition de cette
catégorie intermédiaire que constituent
les terrains agricoles en situation
privilégiée en effet et vous me
permettrez de pas entrer dans
l'intégralité des détails mais si vous
souhaitez avoir davantage de détails
sont et je les tiendrai à votre
disposition la jurisprudence vigoureux
celle que vous venez de citer et qui
consacre la notion de situation
privilégiée s'inscrit en fait dans le
champ du grand teint de l'article l 13
15 du code de l'expropriation
car les terres en cause ne répondent pas
aux critères des terrains à bâtir énoncé
au point 2 du même article on est bien
on reste bien pas dans la création d'une
catégorie nouvelle catégorie
intermédiaire mais bien de fait une sous
catégorie celle des terrains agricoles à
vocation urbaine ont ce n'est pas à la
jurisprudence ne crée pas une nouvelle
catégorie mais intègre cette
sous-catégorie dans l'article dans le
grand est un pardon de l'article que
j'ai cité du code de l'expropriation
on est bien dans que dans la quête et la
sous catégorie des terrains agricoles à
vocation urbaine dès lors l'amendement
proposé ne permet pas de s'affranchir de
la création du juge de fait c'est là le
la suite logique de ce que je viens de
vous décrire
cependant je reconnais bien volontiers à
l'issue de cet examen que la situation
jurisprudentielle autour des valeurs
déterminées en matière d'expropriation
est aujourd'hui peu claires pour bon
nombre d'acteurs donc je m'engage à
travailler avec la chancellerie
puisqu'on est bien dans un dans un
domaine partagé dans les prochains mois
pour trouver des solutions à ces
difficultés que je ne méconnais pas j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion réponse à d'autres
amendements d'identifier sa tombe de
difficultés pas de la même nature qui
portait pas sur cette sous catégorie
mais sur d'autres sujets notamment pour
la cession du foncier public donc nous
allons travailler sur cette question
j'espère que l'attention que nous avons
porté à cette question et la pression de
ma réponse vous permettra si vous
l'acceptez de bien vouloir retirer cet
amendement sinon mon avis monsieur le
sénateur sera défavorable
merci madame la ministre mon cher
collègue vous êtes sollicité pour un
retrait par la commission et la ministre
je voudrais dire merci madame la
ministre des deux réponses qu'elle vient
de me faire et je retire dans la main
d'oeuvre merci chers collègues nous
passons à l'article 4 et vous défendez
l'amendement 57 rectifié monsieur calvet
et ses alliés 53 rectifié pardon j'étais
perdue le présidente madame la ministre
c'est un amendement de suppression de
l'article
bon je vais vous dire que c'est un
amendement de conséquence par rapport à
la position que nous avons prises
précédemment donc je n'en dirai pas plus
si chers collègues l'avis de la
commission
bako c'est un nombre de demandes de
suppression c'est bien sûr un avis
défavorable de la commission puisque
l'article 3 quand même c'est une
disposition clé de de notre projet de
loi dont avis défavorable merci monsieur
le rapporteur votre avis madame la
ministre
mon avis est que comme le rapporteur ce
projet de loi intègre l'ensemble des
établissements publics et donc mon avis
défavorable merci madame la ministre
bien
oui je suis je suis saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public sur l'amendement 53
rectifié à la demande de la commission
oui je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront aux secrétaires un
bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
est ce que le scrutin est ouvert le
scrutin est ouvert plus personne ne
demande à voter ah pardon le scrutin est
ouvert
non je suis supposé là
plus personne ne demande à voter c'est
bon le scrutin est clos j'invite
mesdames et messieurs les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
résultats du scrutin numéro 70 sur
l'amendement 53 rectifié nombre de
votants 346 nombre de suffrages exprimés
346 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
174 pour l'adoption 139 contre 207
le sénat n'a pas adopté et par voie de
conséquence l'article et porte est
adopté nous passons à l'article 5
je dispose d'un amendement 54 qui est
présentée par monsieur calvet la
présidente il est retiré
je vous remercie chers collègues je vais
mettre aux voix l'article 5 qui est pour
merci qui est contre merci abstentions
l'article 5 est adoptée même voix même
votre pour l'article 6 même vote
l'article 6 est adopté même votre pour
l'article cette même vote
l'article 7 est adopté même votre pour
l'article 8
mes chers collègues même vote l'article
1 8è adopter mercy mes chers collègues
nous arrivons à l'article 9
je dispose d'une de l'amendement de deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 31 défendu par
monsieur christian cambon merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre hier
soir au cours de la discussion vous avez
salué la qualité du travail
parlementaire
or j'ai souvenir qu'en première lecture
j'avais défendu un amendement qui est un
amendement de bon sens et qui avait été
votée je le rappelle à l'unanimité par
notre assemblée repris par l'assemblée
nationale cet amendement a été voté
or il se trouve que vous avez profité
des mésaventures constitutionnel de
votre loi pour faire disparaître cet
amendement
je veux dire que ce n'est pas très
respectueux du reste du travail que nous
faisons ici alors que vous l'avez dit à
plusieurs reprises
vous aurez besoin de la mobilisation de
tous et singulièrement des maires sur le
terrain pour faire aboutir votre projet
de quoi s'agit-il
un bailleur social vous le savez peut en
effet vendre un nombre tout à fait
conséquents de logements sociaux
après avoir pris seulement consultation
du maire et avis du préfet ceci n'est
pas une hypothèse vous le savez madame
la ministre puisque je l'avais rappelé
lors de la première lecture un groupe
comme le groupe icade a procédé tenez
vous bien à la vente de 35 mille
logements sociaux au nez et à la barbe
des mères qui en assurait
territorialement la responsabilité
pourquoi ces décisions sont prises elles
sont prises pour des raisons purement
capitalistique qui vise à faire en sorte
de procurer des liquidités pour ces
organismes sociaux et donc pour nous les
maires car nous sommes ici un certain
nombre y compris avoir manifesté en
commun je pense à nos collègues du
groupe communiste et du groupe
socialiste lorsque pareille mésaventure
nous est arrivé dans nos départements
et bien pour nous les maires c'est la
double peine c'est la double peine
puisque évidemment le maire ne donnant
au pad avis conforme sur ses ventes n'a
aucun contrôle et aucune possibilité de
négociation sur la situation même des
locataires sur le seul sur leur
solvabilité sur leurs prix popo proposé
sur le calendrier d'achat sur les
mesures d'accompagnement social que bien
souvent chaque maire va devoir mettre en
oeuvre puisque évidemment un certain
nombre de locataires fait du fait de
leurs revenus ne pourront acheter
et ce sont les locataires modestes qui
vont être touchés première sanction
la seconde madame la ministre c'est que
la vente de ces logements a pour
conséquence immédiate d'entraîner leur
déconventionnement
et donc de faire sortir le nombre de
logements vendus du nombre comptabilisés
dans le cadre des 20 % de la loi sru et
donc qu'on amendement avait simplement
pour but et c'est pour ça que il avait
entraîné l'adhésion à l'unanimité de
cette assemblée
chaque groupe avait pris la parole pour
dire que c'était un amendement de bon
sens
cet amendement a simplement pour but de
renforcer le rôle des maires qui devrait
donner si mon amendement est adopté un
avis conforme et non pas un simple un
simple avis de convenance un avis
conforme et donc de venir face à une
telle opération
de véritables acteurs et non des
spectateurs de ses ventes en bloc
organisée je le rappelle pour des
raisons purement capitalistique
alors madame la ministre j'aimerais
vivement savoir pourquoi vous avez
subrepticement modifier ce texte voté
unanimement par nos assemblées et
remplacé vous avez remplacé l'avis
conforme du du maire non pas par celui
du préfet qui existe actuellement
mais par celui du ministre et je vous
demande un peu mes chers collègues
lorsque pareille mésaventure vous
arrivera monsieur le maire de tours mes
chers collègues du val de marne et c'est
qu'elle quels arguments développés vous
devant un ministre à paris pour faire
vos observations quant à l'opportunité
de telles ventes quant aux conditions
sociales qui vont frapper les petits
locataires qui souvent sont dans ces
immeubles votre texte renforce les
sanctions contre les villes qui se
soustraire à l'obligation d'avoir ou de
réaliser des logements sociaux soit mais
est-il dans ces conditions est il
raisonnable de ne pas leur donner les
moyens de au moins négocier les
modalités de ses ventes en bloc
est il raisonnable de parler d'une
nouvelle étape de décentralisation comme
nos collègues de la majorité s'apprête à
le faire quand loin de renforcer le
pouvoir des maires vous reprenez ce
pouvoir des préfets pour les coller
confié à un ministre que sera à vrai
dire le ministre des difficultés locales
quand j'entends jean fauque opération
conclure j'en appelle à mes collègues de
gauche et je souhaite effectivement que
cet amendement permettent de revenir au
texte initial comme l'unanimité de notre
assemblée l'avait voté merci chers
collègues s'appelle l'amendement 115
actifs y et qui est présentée par
monsieur calvet il ya le même objet il
est retiré donc on discutera sûrs retiré
merci ce combo mongolie merci donc nous
n'allons nous allons nous prononcer sur
le 31 mai sur le rapporteur oui je crois
que monsieur cambon a bien raconter
l'histoire historique de cet amendement
effectivement elle a été présentée lors
de notre dernier débat il ya deux
petites je dirais une attitude dans vos
propos c'est de faire supporter mais le
dira peut-être elle-même dans la
ministre le fait que l ai retiré aux
clés sur ces tristes banques on vous
l'avait dit changer les termes de votre
de notre projet de loi je vous rappelle
que ça a été fait en commission mixte
paritaire et la commission mixte
paritaire souveraine est revenu sur cet
amendement et je dirais que les
représentants du sénat que j'étais ont
été battus là-dessus temps il faut
revenir sur la genèse la deuxième
rectification c'est quand vous dites à
partir du moment où ces logements sont
vendus il ne rentre plus dans le quota
ils ont encore cinq ans pour figurer
quand même dans le coup tu as et pas
immédiats monsieur d'hambourg je crois
que il faut le rappeler
oui mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut quand
même ne pas être aussi à brut dans la
présentation
voilà alors en ce qui concerne
l'amendement lui-même que vous proposez
on la commission n'y est pas favorable
car comme l'indiqué
autre éminent président lors lors des
derniers débats d'une part
l'instauration d'un avis conforme
pourrait conduire à des blocages et
ensuite donner la possibilité au
ministre de trancher
ça me semble être une bonne solution
parce que ça nous permet quand il ya
s'il ya blocage entre le maire et entre
la société qui veut vendre la société où
l'organisme qui veut vendre le logement
je pense que il ne prendra pas pour fait
cause pour l'organisme c'est-à-dire y
sera il y aura une écoute plus attentive
du maire dont même si on revient sur
votre amendement monsieur cambon je
pense que ce qui est proposé est
nettement mieux que ce qui avait été
évoqué tout à fait au début dans le
cadre de notre de notre projet de loi
dont c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission
à moins que vous ne retire y est votre
amendement merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre
oui monsieur le sénateur je tiens à vous
dire effectivement comme l'a dit le
rapporteur que ça n'est pas une une
un changement subreptice mais bien là le
respect du travail parlementaire de tout
le travail parlementaire donc du vote de
l'assemblée nationale qui n'était pas
celui du sénat et de la conclusion de ce
travail en cmp sur ce point là le texte
qui vous est présenté est parfaitement
le texte adopté en cmp que vous aviez
d'ailleurs revoté en séance
ici à l'issue de cette commission mixte
paritaire
je tiens quand même à vous indiquer deux
points à la suite de ce que vient ce que
vient d'indiquer le rapporteur c'est
qu'effectivement on pourrait se
retrouver dans la situation de blocage
et de blocage très forte vis-à-vis de
certains bailleurs et que le point
particulier que vous évoquez c'est celui
d' icade
c'est celui qui a traumatisé nombre
d'élus et je le comprends mais je tiens
à rappeler qu'il s'agit d'une société
filiale de la caisse des dépôts pour
lequel le gouvernement avait quand même
un avis déterminant a donné et je pense
que cette décision d'aucuns l'admettent
et sur l'ensemble des branches croix
était une mauvaise décision mais c'était
une décision du précédent gouvernement
donc il faut quand même essayer de ne
pas faire de généralités sur des cas
particuliers en l'occurrence le cas
particuliers d'icade qui effectivement a
déstabilisé le
l' équilibre du parc immobilier d'un
certain nombre de communes voilà
pourquoi l'avis du gouvernement est
défavorable
merci merci madame la ministre madame
létard
oui simplement pour soutenir
l'amendement déposé par notre collègue
monsieur cambon parce que je pense que
si cadette un cas extrême vu la
proportion que ça représente
il faut bien vous dire que ce ne sera
pas le seul et que ça ne sera pas une
exception que dans des territoires comme
celui d'où je viens le nord où on a
besoin que les bailleurs sociaux ne
vendent pas de patrimoine pour pouvoir
produire ailleurs on commence à avoir
des situations qui qui pointe le bout du
nez
on a un certain nombre de bailleurs qui
pour reconstituer des fonds propres pour
pouvoir aller produire du logement dans
un certain nombre de territoires qui
sont pas forcément ceux où l'on a vendu
des logements c'est à dire où on n'a pas
forcément la possibilité
lorsqu'on vend des logements à des
locataires qui veulent devenir
propriétaires certes c'est bien encore
faut-il que le produit de la vente soit
réutilisée dans le même territoire pour
produire des logements locatifs sociaux
en conte en compensation ses fonds
propres que certains bailleurs vont
devoir aller chercher pour continuer
leur politique de production de logement
social est bien fait que eh bien on se
rend compte que de plus en plus vont
avoir recours à cette pratique de vente
de patrimoine
je vous dis donc sur notre territoire du
nord il ya un certain nombre de
bailleurs sociaux qui sont en train
d'emboîter le pas et qu'ils vont vendre
du patrimoine
je dis donc cet amendement a tout son
sens et qu'il est utile que les élus
locaux soient consultés et à émettre un
avis conforme si on ne veut pas demain
et bien se retrouver dans des situations
même des territoires où les populations
locataires sont en grande difficulté
donc comme l'a dit monsieur cambo ne
pourront peut-être par htc logements
dans lesquels ils sont et non trouveront
peut-être pas d'autres eh bien il faut
se poser des questions avant de
s'embarquer dans quelque chose qui
pourrait avoir beaucoup d'effets pervers
merci madame l'état plus personnellement
de la parole monsieur cambon
oui je suis évidemment très étonné de la
réaction de la majorité parce que encore
une fois j'aurais pu avoir la cruauté de
citer les propos qui avaient été tenus
par les orateurs de chaque groupe et je
suis même étonnée de la pas la réaction
de la ministre d'abord parce que la
version de l'assemblée nationale
reprenez globalement la mienne en la
précisant et avait reconnu le droit des
mères à donner un avis conforme par
ailleurs puisque j'ai l'honneur madame
la ministre d'être votre sénateur
puisque vous êtes toujours conseillère
municipale de villeneuve saint georges
vous savez dans ces départements de la
région parisienne les dégâts qu'entraîne
ce jeu ses ventes en bloc de logements
sociaux
les centaines et des centaines de petits
locataires qui ne qui n'ont aucun moyen
de défense
et seul le maire seul le maire est en
mesure d'amortir le choc
seul le maire est en mesure de négocier
avec ces géants du logement social
je trouve que votre réponse est
insuffisante pour ne pas dire qu'elle
peut friser l'indignité par rapport aux
engagements qui sont les vôtres
je ne comprends absolument pas votre
réaction et bien évidemment nous
demanderons un scrutin public sur ce
vote de telle sorte que ça que chacun
s'engage et lorsque nos élus nos
collègues communistes nous ont demandé
de venir manifester avec eux je pense à
chevilly-larue notamment qui a été
touchée pour près de 1000 logements et
bien le maire de chevilly larue
connaîtra et bien d'autres mais
reconnaîtront les réactions que vous
avez aujourd'hui
merci cher collègue madame le ministre
cambon je dois vous dire avec une
certaine franchise que je n'accepte pas
votre terme d'un dignité mais absolument
pas je vous remercie parce que je crois
que vous pouvez quand même savoir que la
politique du précédent gouvernement
étaient une politique massive et
volontariste de vente d'achille m
c'est une politique avec laquelle se
gouverne bien sûr c'est exactement la
politique ex et c'est exactement la
politique avec laquelle ce gouvernement
a rompu mais ce que vous dénoncez
c'était une politique volontaire assumée
revendiquée et exiger exigé de la part
des bailleurs hlm pour lequel pour
lesquelles on ne donnait pas droit à des
aides à la pierre suffisante en disant
qu'il n'avait qu'à vendre du patrimoine
pour pouvoir reconstituer l'offre et
construire de nouvelles opérations
donc c'est quand même paradoxal je vous
ai répondu de manière posée est calme
mais je dois vous dire que la politique
vous dénoncez avec beaucoup de virulence
et vous avez raison c'est la politique
qui avait été mené de manière
extrêmement volontariste assumée
revendiquée avec une obligation de
résultat qui pesait sur les bailleurs
pour vendre leur parc donc je crois que
je crois qu'il ya quand même une grande
une grande indélicatesse dans vos propos
et dans la mise en cause que vous faites
de ma personne et de notre politique
au contraire nous souhaitons qu'il n'y
ait pas de blocages entre les bailleurs
et les communes que les ministres ont
toujours très sensibles sont tous si
vous donner le pouvoir au maire voulu
donner un pouvoir de blocage à pouvoir
de blocage à la politique du bailleur
lebas le maire a toujours la possibilité
de pouvoir gérer les choses avec un
office public dans lequel il est
représenté vous ne pouvez pas et c'est
moi qui le dit enlever toute possibilité
d'intervention bailleurs sociaux la
coordination est géré comme elle l'est
sur beaucoup d'autres sujets et elle les
fait l effet sous l'égide du ministère
pour les situations de blocage c'est je
pense une position équilibrée
responsable mais vous indigner à ce
point la politique était menée qui était
une politique d'obligations de vente du
patrimoine me paraît pour le coup un
petit peu à contre emploi
merci madame la ministre monsieur dubois
madame la ministre vous venez 10éme ans
qu'on ne peut pas empêcher un d'ailleurs
d'arbitré eh ben je pense qu'on vient de
dire madame l'état qu'il va y avoir de
nombreux bailleurs qui vont arbitrer
gérer dans les temps qui viennent parce
que tout simplement
mais pour construire ils doivent mettre
de plus en plus de fonds propres dans
les opérations
c'est incontournable ils ont aussi des
réhabilitations extrêmement importante a
mené un raid dans les politiques à
travers l'anru ce qui fait que de toute
manière un et vous venez de le dire à
juste titre nous ne pouvons pas empêcher
ces arbitral mais pour le moins puisque
le maire est pénalisé un moment donné
s'il n'atteint pas ses quotas
il me semble que la moindre des choses
serait qu'il soit informé et qu'il
puisse agir
bret dans ce domaine est pour le moins
pour pour le moins madame la ministre
pour le moins où elle est informée
qu'ils puissent agir qu'il puisse agir
puisqu'il est concerné il va payer
éventuellement des pénalités alors qu'il
n'y sera pour rien qu'il n'y sera pour
rien et des pénalités qui sont quand
même de plus en plus lourdes
donc à un moment donné il faut avoir de
la cohérence et la cohérence et bien
c'est qu'effectivement le maire puisse
émettre un avis sur la vente et si si
vous ne voulez pas de mettre cela à
n'était au moins que les logements
vendus
-y'a aux locataires soient comptabilisés
dans les 25 % par les fouette vous faut
de la logique et de la cohérence un bout
de la logique et de la cohérence
les bailleurs c'est incontournable
demain auront des arbitrages à faire
vous venez de le dire soit le maire est
consulté et il peut intervenir s'il ne
peut pas agir et être consultés et agir
et bien qu'on comptabilise dans les 25 %
les logements vendus aurait aux
locataires merci monsieur dit merci
monsieur dubois monsieur le rapporteur
bon je ne peux pas laisser continuer de
dire monsieur dubois
nier la réalité là le maire est saisie
pour avis et donc ne dis pas qu'il n'ait
pas saisi pour avis premièrement
deuxièmement deuxièmement s'il est en
désaccord
il peut saisir le ministre ce qui est
non non mais je pense que c'est mieux
que de saisir le préfet c'est mieux que
le 16e problème c'est qu'en bon et il a
une possibilité de saisie de montrer son
désaccord et je pense que si on
désaccord entre le maire quelle que soit
la taille de la commune est un opérateur
il vaut mieux que ce soit beau que ça
vienne devant le ministre moi je le
pense vraiment deuxièmement je peux pas
laisser dire à monsieur du mois que si
les logements sont vendus ils ne sont et
ne compte plus pendant cinq ans il
continue de faire partie du des 25% dans
sa ne s'annulent monsieur cambon les six
mois terminées quand même
ouais on va pas vous laisser dire
n'importe quoi il y avait il y avait je
vous rappelle je vous rappelle qu'il y
avait deux abstentions la mienne et
celle de mon président voilà non mais le
bon voilà mais c'est du détail on avait
compris puisque ils avaient été intégrés
dans le texte de loi
deuxièmement je reviens dessus quand
même ce n'est c'est en cmp que ça a été
enlevé voilà la cmp par le passé par le
passé vous savez comment ça fonctionne
et voilà je reviendrai pas sur la
réponse de madame le ministre qui est
quand même une réponse pertinente quand
on regarde quand on regarde ce qui a été
fait les instructions qui ont été
données par le passé et la réalité
d'aujourd'hui
il ya une sacrée différence monsieur
cambon dont il faut pas être de mauvaise
foi dont nous dont nous avons avis
défavorable de la commission porte et
nous allons avoir maintenant scrutin
public merci messieurs n'apportèrent
monsieur dit l'un
oui mais je m'exprime pour dire
exactement là c'est bien de me faire
confiance parce que je vais dire
exactement la même chose que le
rapporteur c'est non je n'ai pas changé
d'avis simplement il ya aussi dans votre
proposition mais parler monsieur dit là
il ya aussi des effets pervers que vous
connaissez très bien donc je pense que
cet accord qui a été trouvé à la cmp me
paraît bon c'est un équilibre et il faut
le respecter
si chers collègues j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public par le groupe
ump sur l'amendement numéro 31 présenté
par notre collègue christian cambon je
vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est défavorable que l'avis du
gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour remettront un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre un
bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
mes chers collègues le scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames et messieurs les
secrétaires a procédé au dépouillement
du scrutin
merci madame la ministre michelle
collègues résultats du scrutin numéro 71
sur l'amendement numéro 31 nombre de
votants 347 nombre de suffrages exprimés
347 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
174 pour l'adoption 171 contre 176 le
sénat n'a pas adopté la plus sûre
bien j'aime et aux voies l'article 9 qui
pour mercy qui est contre merci
abstentions l'article ne fait adopter
nous en venons à l'article 10 g 2
inscrits en par action article monsieur
serge nation monsieur alain fouché
monsieur dassault vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente madame 2000
chers collègues ce que je vais vous dire
vous concerne tous
en tout cas ceux qui sont mères quel que
soit votre appartenance politique
car sous les mers sont confrontés à ces
mêmes problèmes
repas d'abord des garanties d'emprunt
c'est qu'ils ont réussi une aberration
financière car elle oblige toutes les
communes a signé une garantie d'emprunt
caisse des dépôts or elles n'ont
évidemment aucun fonds propres pour
tenir compte de ces garanties
on les oblige par une délibération
conseil municipal a payé la caisse des
dépôts à la première de monde sans
discussion 6 un bailleur social est
défaillant et elle garantit son % des
emplois alors que pour le moment elles
n'ont droit qu'à 20 consent de logements
cela devrait être invitée
inconstitutionnel car il devrait être
interdit à qui que ce soit a obligés à
sa a réalisé une garantie d'emprunt
auprès de quelqu'un qui n'a aucun moyen
de crypter cette garantie
on les oblige infi a à faire c'est
garanti sous pratique sous prétexte
qu'on n'a jamais encore vu un bailleur
social faire faillite
alors comme le charisme qu'aucun valeurs
sociales desa y a signé la garantie
d'emprunt recracher leona et tout ça
pour que le bailleur puissent bénéficier
de l'eau pour cent des cas nuit alors
qu'il pourrait très bien
garantir auprès d'une compagnie
d'assurance deuxièmement est anormal que
les communes ne disposent que de 20 %
des logements sociaux construits sur le
territoire alors que de nombreux ennuis
serait attendu logement en étant mal
logés et ne comprennent pas pourquoi on
lui reste remue pas ces logements et que
l'on fait venir d'autres personnes à
leur place c'est pour ça je vous propose
un jour de penser le contingentement le
contingent des mères à 50%
vous les 20 % et l'a trouvée 30% pour le
1 % et 20 % pour le préfet les maires
pourront ainsi disposer de plus de par
seulement pour leurs administrés
cela n'empêche pas d'ailleurs les
préfets dans l'est dans les communes des
familles d'un comportement n'est pas
toujours souhaitable tant les rangements
de naître elles compromettent ainsi la
bonne réputation la sécurité des
quartiers réhabiliter et surtout surtout
sans demander l'avis des maires
responsables de la sécurité par ailleurs
les maires sont confrontés dans ses
opérations à l'augmentation du nombre
d'enfants à cause des locataires qui
viennent dans ces nouveaux logements et
sans avoir les moyens de tagant dire où
se construire de nouvelles écoles les
communes qui doit foncer d'école non pas
des moyens nécessaires lorsqu'il ya des
augmentations de locataire à cause de la
construction de ces logements sociaux
excuse-moi du problème il faut leur
attribuer des subventions par le conseil
régional le conseil général
il sera nécessaire or ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui et elles sont
confrontées à ces problèmes concernant
les communes faisant partie de
l'opération une communauté de communes
je pense qu'il serait normal que
l'obligation des 25% de logements ne
soit pas comptabilisée par commune
mais en moyenne dans l'agglomération car
dans libération et peut avoir des
communes étions beaucoup plus de 25% qui
pourrait les utiliser pour celles qui
ont en moins et donc cela résoudrait
beaucoup de problèmes pour les petites
communes qui n'ont pas en non plus tous
les moyens d'avoir les erreurs
nécessaire enfin une réglementation
beaucoup plus rigoureuse devrait être la
piste au logement privé insalubres il y
en a beaucoup
malheureusement et son sursaturé par des
marchands de sommeil qui pourrissent les
quartiers avec des loyers créé lui voilà
je voulais proposer une dame miss
l'aberration des garanties d'emploi
impossible d'ignorer le l'obligation
pour les mères de disposer la plupart la
possibilité première des choses est de
50 % de logements sociaux -les de 2 1%
le contrôle prend la mer des locataires
envoyé par le préfet allait cesser de
subventionner le subventionner les
maires pour leur permettre de construire
aux écoles ou les agrandir le décompte
non plus par commune n'est pas
agglomérations pour les 25% et une
réglementation plus rigoureuse de
marchands de sommeil
voilà je vais vous dire mes amis je n'ai
pas proposer d'amendement pour faciliter
les choses se propose de vous propose
ses confiance pour qu'un jour vous
bûcher adopté ces dispositions pour le
bénéfice de tous les maires des communes
de france le grand merci
si monsieur l'assaut la parole et alain
fouché
madame la présidente madame la ministre
nous allons évoquer les taux les bloquer
les communes pénalisé simplement mon
intervention par rapport aux sanctions
madame la ministre qui sont prévues les
maires concernés ont besoin je crois
d'être rassuré le texte définit des
procédures mais ils craignent une
censure automatique pour les
collectivités qui ne rentreraient pas
dans l'est dans les clous se souhaite
donc pour précisiez vos intentions
plusieurs possibilités doivent être
distingués la municipalité et j'en
connais de tous horizons qui pour des
raisons de craintes électoralistes ou de
refus de solidarité interdit tout
logement social doit être durement
sanctionné par contre la municipalité
qui a hérité de la carence de conseils
municipaux précédent doit bénéficier
d'un jugement différent
quel d'élèves doivent être accordées
mais même avec des délais ne sera pas
facile de répondre à la loi
enfin la municipalité qui ne peut compte
tenu du coût du foncier acquérir du
terre des terrains doit aussi bénéficier
d'une étude particulière soit des délais
et pourquoi pas des aides financières de
l'état pour pouvoir acquérir des
terrains et construire des logements
sociaux chaque situation devra donc être
examinées au cas par cas
tel est mon avis et c'est ce que
souhaite aussi les élus de différents
horizons
il ya de nombreux maires de bonne foi
qui ne pourront arriver à ce niveau en
2025 vous indiquiez à l'assemblée
nationale au député fromentin qu'une
circulaire serait envoyée au préfet pour
qu'il tienne compte de la bonne foi des
mères une commission dans chaque
département avec le préfet naturellement
est la bonne solution
pouvez vous nous indiquer plus
précisément ce qu'il en sera sur ce
point comment pourra-t-elle fonctionner
quelle sont les préconisations qui
seront donnés je crois que ce débat est
intéressant et il permet au maire
d'avoir un certain nombre d'informations
sur l'avenir
merci chers collègues j'en viens à
l'amendement cinq ans est rectifié biz
présentée par monsieur d'allier merci
madame la présidente madame le ministre
mes chers collègues nous voici au coeur
de ce texte puisque effectivement il
s'agit de faire passer
l'obligation de construction de 20 à 25%
madame la ministre je vous l'avais dit
en première lecture ce n'est pas tant le
fait passer à 20 de 20 à 25% qui nous
pose problème c'est les conditions dans
lesquelles effectivement vous comptez
demandé aux collectivités locales dit
aller et je rappellerai immédiatement
que la loi sru la première qui avait été
j'allais dire âprement discutés
notamment de notre côté a finalement un
donné des résultats est le nôtre
rapporteur le redis dans le rapport
qu'il a rendu etc en fait peu de
collectivités et même très peu de
collectivités se trouvant constat de
carence et parmi celles qui sont en
constat de carence très peu de mer
affirme ouvertement il y en a
quelques-uns ne rien vouloir faire un
parce que la population leur commune ne
le souhaiterait pas donc la loi votés
précédemment apporter ses effets on a
financé 135 mille logements sociaux
l'année dernière il n'y a peut-être pas
assez de pl a parmi ces logements
sociaux on peut en discuter mais en tous
les cas des résultats ont été obtenus et
la première loi a porté ses fruits
les collectivités avaient 20 ans pour se
remettre à niveau
vingt ans celle qui ont respecté leurs
objectifs triennaux c'était le cas de la
mienne ont donc quasiment fait la moitié
du chemin qui leur avait été demandé
or ces collectivités vous allez leur
demander maintenant dans un délai
beaucoup plus court puisque c'est
maintenant une douzaine d'années dont il
est question de construire trois fois
plus pour ce qui concerne ma
collectivité de logements qu'elle n'en
avait construit dans la période
précédente
madame la ministre je vous le redis vous
allez poussé dans les cordes et poussé à
la faute
nombre de collectivités locales qui
avait jusqu'à présent respecter
absolument respecter les objectifs
triennaux qui a été fixé et cela à mon
sens ce n'est pas accès
par dessus le marché comme si ça n'était
pas suffisant et quelles que soient les
assurances qu'on pourra nous donner vous
l'avait déjà fait en première lecture le
texte prévoit des sanctions financières
qui sont très lourde puisque vous
multiplier par cinq les pénalités alors
effectivement pourra regarder dans le
détail et en fonction de la situation le
préfet pourra peut-être il n'en reste
pas moins que le texte prévoit des
sanctions financières qui sont très
lourdes et ses sanctions financières
vont tomber à une période où nous le
savons tout sur ses bancs les
collectivités locales vont se voir
confronté à une diminution très
importante de leurs recettes que ça soit
les dotations de l'état
que ça soit les recettes liées aux
droits de mutation donc dans une période
très difficile pour les finances
communales
vous allez nous demande de nous demander
de construire beaucoup plus mais si on
construit des logements
madame la ministre vous le savez il faut
aussi construire les équipements publics
qui vont avec donc une commune va le
voir construire financer les équipements
publics voir ses ressources baisser
c'est une quasi certitude et
potentiellement se voit infliger des
pénalités financières qui la conduiront
qui pourrait conduire certaines de ces
collectivités dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles
alors madame la ministre cet amendement
propose tout simplement j'allais dire
malheureusement de supprimer cet article
ce que nous aurions préféré c'est
pouvoir discuter les modalités
ça n'avait pas été possible en première
lecture voilà pourquoi je suis bien
obligé cet après-midi de vous proposer
mes chers collègues de supprimer
l'article en question
merci monsieur d'allier j'ai demandé
l'avis de monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur d'allier vous avez conclu
en disant que malheureusement vous
demander de supprimer l'article
vous comprendrez donc demandant la
suppression de cet article qui est quand
même une des mesures les plus
importantes de ce projet de loi la
commission et le rapporteur donne un
avis défavorable
bon je m'en tiens là parce que j'aurais
pu répondre point par point à votre
plaidoyer pro domo pour supprimer ce
texte de loi
m'est avis défavorable de la commission
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
oui j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
je crois à hyères pour ceux qui étaient
là tard en clin d'oeil les mêmes qui
aujourd'hui considèrent que le cette
augmentation de seuil est un souci
considéré il y a dix ans que la loi sru
était une chose à surtout ne pas faire
et ce en fait se félicite aujourd'hui de
son existence en demandant à ce qu'elle
n'évolue pas donc en donnant un avis
défavorable à cet amendement pour
maintenir cet article je prépare le
débat des dix prochaines années où vous
fait ou vous féliciterez de l'existence
de cette loi et du seuil de 25%
merci madame la ministre je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement 57 rectifié
bis présenté par notre collègue d'allier
avec deux avis défavorables commission
et gouvernement qui est pour
merci qui est contre merci abstentions
l'amendement n'est pas adopté j'en viens
l'amendement 55 rectifié qui est
présentée par monsieur calvet monsieur
lassant monsieur l'a sauvé
monsieur calvet monsieur vallier
il s'agit madame la présidente madame la
miss mes chers collègues de permettre
effectivement dans le décompte de ses
25% de comptabiliser les logements en
accession sociale à la propriété
considérant que ce dispositif de
l'accession sociale a un double avantage
il permet puisqu'il vise un public qui à
priori à des ressources faibles et qui
la plupart du temps habite en logement
social il permet un de permettre à des
familles d'accéder à la propriété et ce
faisant de libérer un logement social
par ailleurs donc nous considérons que
ce dispositif est intéressant qu'il
convient de le soutenir voilà pourquoi
il nous semblerait utile qu'ils puissent
être pris en compte dans votre des
comptes relève le ministre merci chers
collègues l'avis de la commission
monsieur rapporteur oui madame la
présidente c'est un amendement le
premier d'une longue série qui aborde la
même problématique et qui voudrait que
nous intégrions l'accession sociale à la
propriété dans les logements sociaux
pris en compte dans l'article 55 de la
loi sru
lors des débats que nous avons eus
lors de l'examen du premier projet de
loi enfin du projet de loi en septembre
j'avais fait référence j'avais dit que
le débat avait été tranché notamment
avec un de vos illustres rapporteur qui
avait dit qu'il n'était pas nécessaire
et il avait développé sa avec talent
nécessaire de prendre en compte
l'accession sociale à la propriété je
voudrais au delà de cet exemple dire
quand même que si on prenait en compte
l'accession sociale à la propriété
nous nous trouverions avec un déficit de
construction de logement je vous
rappelle que nous avons un million sept
cent mille de personnes qui souhaitent
avoir un logement à caractère social et
que si nous le faisions ben la
production de logements pour m mettre à
disposition des locataires qui sont dans
la demande ne pourrait pas se faire dans
ce serait à contre-courant de la
politique que nous voulons poursuivre et
des objectifs qui nous ont été assignés
par le président de la république et que
met en forme le gouvernement et madame
la ministre
dans cet avis défavorable si monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis du gouvernement madame
la ministre
oui nous avons longuement débattu ici de
cette question je le dis l'accession
sociale est un des éléments du parc
locatif c'est pourquoi il est elle est
prise en compte au titre de des
possibilités de décote sur la cession
des terrains publics néanmoins les 25%
concert concerne les logements locatifs
sociaux ce n'est absolument pas exclusif
de la réalisation en complément de
projets d'accession sociale à la vie du
gouvernement n'a pas changé sur ce point
il est défavorable
merci madame la ministre je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement 55
rectifiée présentée par notre collègue
vallier qui a deux avis défavorables
gouvernement et commission qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci abstentions l'amendement n'est pas
adopté je suis saisie de quatre
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 13 présentée par
monsieur dubois la ministre cet
amendement s'inscrit j'allais dire dans
la même veine que ceux déposés par nos
collègues calvet d'allier c'est
effectivement 6,6 et 25% pourquoi pas
moi je suis toujours été favorable à
l'article 55 de la loi sru très
favorables devraient aux 20% mais mes 25
% avec des pénalités multiplié par cinq
je pense que le parcours résidentiel
doit être pris en compte et que
l'accession à la propriété doit être
prise en compte et que d'ailleurs les
logements sociaux vendus à leurs
locataires doivent aussi intégrer même
s'ils sont comptabilisés cinq ans et
bien qu'il soit comptabilisé au moins
dix ans ou en totalité
et puis le débat qui avait eu lieu ici
avec dominique braille puisque j'aurai
le rapporteur a fait allusion à ce débat
à juste titre d'ailleurs
sauf qu'on débattait à l'époque sur 20%
et non pas sur 25
quand on augmente de 5% et que surtout
on multiplie les pénalités par cinq sa
mairie veut dire est qu'il y ait
effectivement un débat qui s'élargissent
d'autant que encore une fois le parcours
résidentiel avec l'accession sociale
aurait certainement le mérite de libérer
des logements locatifs hlm est de faire
en sorte que cette fluidité retrouvée
parce qu'on il faut reconnaître aussi
qu'en période de crise il n'y a plus de
fluidité dans le parc hlm aurait sans
aucun doute aurait amélioré les choses
c'est la raison pour laquelle je verrai
je regrette totalement ses 25% et 7 non
prise en compte
le raid du parcours résidentiel merci
monsieur dubois
la maman numéro 124 présentée par
monsieur richard ouimet mme la
présidente
cet amendement s'inscrit dans le même
esprit que l'amendement 57 rectifié bis
mais monsieur rapporteur celui ci ne
demande pas la suppression donc j'espère
que il aura il trouvera grâce à vos yeux
pourtant naturellement il vise à revenir
au quota initial de 20 % les motifs sont
simples moi j'en ai recensé au moins
trois d'abord et vous le savez bien
beaucoup de communes ne parviennent pas
à atteindre le quota de 20% malgré tous
les efforts qu'elle déploie en effet
alors que les communes privilégié elles
ne font rien d'autre
la mixité sociale en réalisant à la fois
des logements sociaux et des habitations
d'accession le parc de logements
s'agrandit automatiquement et il crie
pso facto de nouvelles obligations de
logement social c'est gelé déjà dit la
fois dernière c'est la course à
l'échalote et donc dans la mesure où les
communes ne parviennent pas à atteindre
le quota de 20 % pourquoi vous feront
passer à 25% et ne parviennent pas à ma
20 pourquoi arrivera-t-elle à 25 si ce
n'est si on fait ça c'est pour parvenir
à une imposition déguisée de ces
collectivités territoriales c'est pas
possible autrement
deuxième motif les subventions de l'état
ne parviennent pas ça a déjà été dit
hier soir tard de couvrir les besoins
évalués à 2,7 milliards d'euros excusez
du peu par an sur la seule période 2014
alors pourquoi inscrire un tel objectif
alors qu'on n'arrivera pas à financer et
enfin les sanctions qui sont opérés par
les collectivités qui n'y parviennent
pas ne changeront rien à la chose
vous avez compris que il faut absolument
en rester à 20% dans un souci
d'efficacité
alors je sais bien que vous voulez un
conforme mais peut-être que vu
l'importance et l'exemplarité de mes
raisons vous changerez d'avis merci
merci chers collègues nous continuons
cette série d'amendements
avec l'amendement 121 présentée par
monsieur bah oui par malin de chair
l'amendement 118
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues nous cet
amendement voyez-vous et dans l'esprit
contraire aux précédents puisque nous
souhaitons porter à 30% l'obligation de
présence de logements sociaux en zone
tendue tout en maintenant bien sûr à 20%
pour le reste des collectivités
concernées par la loi sru
pour nous il ne s'agit pas de d'une
figure de style voyez vous mes chers
collègues ni d'une surenchère gratuit
mais simplement d'une urgence sociale
que vous n'entendez pas apparemment et à
laquelle il nous faut répondre oui cette
urgence sociale s'illustre par le fait
qu'un nombre accru de nos concitoyens se
trouvent confrontées à la pauvreté
selon un récent sondage près d'un
français sur deux se considère comme
pauvres ou en passe de le devenir
écoutez cela mes chers collègues
la récente conférence sur la pauvreté
l'exclusion l'a d'ailleurs rappelé vous
y avez pris des engagements importants
madame la ministre
permettre la présence de 30 % de
logements sociaux en zone tendue est un
impératif moral et social en
représentant la seule garantie d'une
réelle mixité sociale si utile pour la
construction de la ville et nous ne
sommes pas les seuls à le demander la
région capitale elle-même l'a compris et
elle a défini dans son schéma
dans le cas de son schéma directeur une
obligation de construction à hauteur de
30 % puisque le projet de loi proroge le
terme de l'accomplissement de cette
obligation à 2025
et lorsque nous savons qu'aujourd'hui 64
% de nos concitoyens 64% mes chers
collègues peuvent prétendre au logement
social
il ne paraît pas déraisonnable
d'affirmer que l'obligation de
construction de logements sociaux doit
être porté à 30 % en zone tendue
tel est le sens de cet amendement madame
la présidente merci madame cher
j'appelle l'amendement 121 présenté par
notre collègue nous collectons chez
aussi cet amendement concerne le taux
bon lors de du texte lorsqu'il a été
présenté la première fois en septembre
j'étais intervenu sur mon souhait d'un
principe simple ce qui est celui la
solidarité nationale pour le logement
j'avais également souhaité que des
garanties importantes soient consentis
pour favoriser l'acquisition de
logements par les locataires de leur
logement car la demande est très forte
et en province il demande très forte et
j'ai besoin d'y répondre
ce qui finalement n'a pas bougé dans ce
texte un amendement que je défends ici
vise en fait à un principe de réalité
oui à une augmentation des logements
sociaux mais de façon plus progressive
en effet dans les communes rurales et je
prends l'exemple de mon département dans
la vienne où dans la région poitou
charentes
l'application de la loi sru pourra
s'avérer très compliqué à mettre en
place à 25 % de logements sociaux dans
les communes quelle que soit leur
couleur
les obligations fixées par la loi ne
doivent pas handicaper sa mise en oeuvre
on ne peut pas ignorer la difficulté
pour certains maires de construire du
logement social
par contre je souhaite effectivement que
des amendes plus forte soit infligée aux
communes qui ont les moyens financiers
et des terrains pour le faire mon
amendement vise donc tout en soutenant
le principe même donc l'augmentation des
logements sociaux à faire en sorte que
plus de communier taxés en 2025
en passant son taux à 22,5 au lieu de 25
chez je vais demander l'avis de la
commission donc sur deux amendements
identiques
le très zélé semaine 15 le 118 et le 121
merci mais la présidente dont les deux
premiers amendements visent à atteindre
le même but c'est-à-dire à rester à
faire du surplace en reste à 20%
on va pas 25% dont ça remet en cause
quand même le dispositif essentiel de la
loi qui vous est présentée aujourd'hui
bon je la réalité quand même et je vous
entends j'entends notre collègue c'est
qu'ils manquent quand même un million 17
faire un million sept cent mille
personnes n'ont pas de logement à
caractère social dont vous nous dites il
faut rester on va gérer c'est très bien
comme ça avait pour ça comment on fait
pour je dirais permettre à ces personnes
dans la difficulté de pouvoir bénéficier
d'un logement à caractère social
est-ce que vous avez d'autres solutions
vous en avez pas vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas il ya un déficit important de
logement social dont la seule façon de
créer des logements plus c'est de mettre
la pression de passer à 25% dont compte
tenu de je dirais de la remise en cause
du projet de loi il y avait entendu un
avis défavorable sur les deux
amendements similaires sur l'amendement
de notre collègue mirail shirt
elle avait fait le même elle avait
déposé le même amendement la dernière
fois alors c'est le contraire
c'est-à-dire qu'elle considère qu'il
faut aller jusqu'à 30% et quand
j'entends son argumentation en disant on
est dans le cadre d'une urgence sociale
je m'accorde sur les mots du genre
social
mais est ce qu'il est est-ce qu'il
serait souhaitable de passer de 25 à 30%
jeu nous pensons que 25%
c'est une première étape dont bien
entendu ce dont bien entendu
donc bien entendu bien entendu mes chers
collègues
c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission mais je souhaiterais qu'elle
puisse retirer son amendement
le l'amendement qui est présenté par
notre collègue foucher lui et de la même
logique c'est à dire il considère que
20% c'est pas satisfaisant mais pour des
raisons un peu différente il dit pas 25%
22 5% et d'étaler bon là aussi vous
comprendrez que nous avons proposé notre
ministre a proposé un projet de loi avec
des objectifs clairs les 25%
ben ce n'est pas négociable autrement ça
sa vie de totalement le contenu de cette
loi des dons c'est également un avis
défavorable
même si les raisons sont tout à fait
différente que celle des deux pour les
deux premiers amendements
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
gouvernement madame le ministre
oui sur les amendements 13 et 124 je
voudrais vous dire effectivement la même
chose que ce que vient d'indiquer le
rapporteur c'est que il a été fait le
choix d'aller au delà d'aller au delà
dans deux dimensions
la première c'est qu'il faut aller plus
plus loin en termes de pourcentage de
logements locatifs sociaux dans les
zones tendues et la deuxième il faut que
les obligations soient à temps
c'est-à-dire qu'elles soient identifiés
de manière précise parce que le triennal
glissant à je le rappelle permis de
faire progresser les communes concernées
par l'article 55 de 13 à 14% en moyenne
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas rempli tous
ses objectifs par l'échec que représente
le principe du triennal glissant donc
voilà pourquoi la l'avis du gouvernement
est défavorable et que il nous semble
que le taux retenu est le bon taux
madame cherchons nous avons déjà eu
cette discussion d'ailleurs vous votre
amendement s'appuie sur des sur des
engagements qui existe déjà sur
certaines intercommunalités ou certaines
dents certains plh parce qu'il ya des
endroits où les besoins existent mais
nous nous prenons et nous avons fait le
choix de déposer un projet de loi pour
l'ensemble du territoire français donc
pour les zones tendues sur l'ensemble du
territoire français pas pour les cas
particuliers
c'est pourquoi je vous inviterai à
retirer votre amendement est sinon mon
avis sera défavorable en considérant qui
a effectivement un certain nombre de cas
pour lesquels les 30% sont nécessaires
mais qu'ils sont prévues dans le cadre
des plh enfin monsieur foucher sur votre
amendement intermédiaire vous pointez un
élément intéressant qui est que
certaines communes sont pas dans un
besoin de passer ce qu'ils sont des
communes concernées par la loi à partie
par l'article 55 de la loi sru actuels
sont ne semble pas concernée par une
situation de tension qui nécessiterait
d'aller jusqu'à jusqu'à 25%
mais ce que je veux vous dire sur ce
point c'est que ce qui est prévu dans le
projet de loi qui n'existait pas dans le
la loi existante c'est que les communes
qui ne sont pas en zone tendue resteront
à 20% et pour parler de la commune de
chauvigny que vous connaissez bien
j'imagine qui est concerné par l'article
55 actuellement elle ne sera sans doute
il ya tout d'ailleurs à la
quasi-certitude pas concernés par le
passage à 25% puisqu'elle ne se situe
pas dans une zone tendue donc nous avons
introduit cette souplesse pour répondre
à la spécificité d'un certain nombre
d'agglomérations qui doivent avoir ce
seuil de 20% mais dont on sent bien
qu'elle ne sont pas spécifiquement
concernés par la nécessité d'aller
jusqu'au seuil de 25% donc plutôt que
d'aller un seuil intermédiaire comme
vous le proposez pour l'ensemble des
communes
nous nous avons fait le choix d'avoir un
seuil de 25% et pas de 30 la réponse est
celle que j'ai faite à madame cherche de
25 % pour l'ensemble des communes en
zones tendues c'est à dire que les
communes qui sont en zones détendues
resteront au seuil actuel de 20 % c'est
pourquoi je vous propose de retirer
également cet amendement
merci madame la ministre je vais mettre
en voix l'amendement 13 et l'amendement
124 qui sont identiques qui ont eu deux
avis défavorables commission et
gouvernement qui est pour
merci contre
merci abstentions ces deux amendements
ne sont pas adoptées j'en viens
l'amendement 119 madame cherche vous
avez une demande d'être sollicités pour
une demande de retrait vous l'aimez vous
le maintenez la maman est maintenue donc
je vais les mettre aux voix
l'amendement 118 il ya eu deux demandes
de retrait commission et gouvernement
qui est pauvre
merci contre merci abstentions
la maman n'est pas adopté la maman 121
de monsieur foucher gevo merci chers
collègues bien oui nous allons passer à
l'amendement 123 rectifié bis présentée
par monsieur gérard larcher vous avez la
parole oui madame la présidente madame
la ministre nous allons venir
spécifiquement en ile de france et nous
allons venir dans la grande couronne
d'île de france
or le texte tel que vous le proposez
demande à des territoires qui sont des
territoires de grandes couronnes dont
les caractéristiques sont des
caractéristiques plus proche de la
province
je pense particulièrement à la question
des transports en commun que vous
connaissez bien et ces territoires on
leur impose pour les communes comprises
entre 1500 et 3500 habitants des efforts
qu'elles ne seront pas en capacité de
fournir pour un certain nombre de
raisons tout d'abord il ya un schéma
directeur de la région ile-de-france qui
a prévu avec à côté un texte sur le
grand paris que l'on maîtrise
l'étalement urbain est donc le
coefficient de croissance dans ces
territoires est en moyenne dans le cadre
des scot en préparation de 0,75 et donc
l'échéance 2025
avec un tel taux relève d'une grande
impossibilité voilà pourquoi je pense
qu'il faut réexaminer cette politique
pour que nous mettions en cohérence ce
qui nous est demandé par le futur schéma
directeur
parce qu'ils aient
mende est tout simplement par la
situation des transports en commun
périco et or on sait que plus on éloigne
et un colloque récent qui se tenait au
sénat de l'agglomération de la ville
sentent plus ce sont des gens modestes
plus ce sont des gens qui sont en
situation de difficulté qui loge dans le
logement social
et je dois dire que l'effort qu'il faut
conduire il faut le conduire avec une
certaine harmonie voilà pourquoi je
plaide pour revenir à la zone agglomérée
l'unité urbaine de paris au sens de
l'insee
ça va paraît cohérent ça ne dédouane pas
de faire des efforts en matière de
logement social
mais ces efforts doivent être faits au
rythme des documents d'urbanisme que
vous êtes en train d'adopter à la région
d'île de france et que nous avons
adoptées dans le cadre du texte du grand
paris
merci monsieur larcher je vais demander
donc l'avis de la commission sur
l'amendement 123 26 bis oui monsieur
larcher vous vous demandez dont à ce que
les communes de
moins de 3500 habitants 2500 3500
habitants de la grande couronne ne soit
plus dans l'obligation de d'être je
dirais dans l'obligation de la loi de la
loi sru asie sont pourtant depuis 2000
depuis la loi sru telle qu'elle a été
mise en place
on ne comprendrait pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui lors de l'examen d'un projet
de loi qui vise à produire plus de
logements à caractère social on
exonérerait des communes qui sont depuis
depuis 2000 et puis je pense que ça
serait compris d'autant d'autant plus
que ou d'autant moins que il ya vraiment
un problème de logement dans la couronne
précités nous avons une demande forte de
logements nous sommes en zone tendue et
il faut y répondre tout simplement pour
faire face aux demandes de logement de
nos citoyennes et doux si julien qui
dans les millions 700 mille qui sont
demandeurs une grande partie habite ce
territoire dont vous comprendrez que la
commission émet un avis défavorable
on va pas revenir en arrière par rapport
à des avancées qui ont été obtenus en
2000 avec ce projet de loi sru
merci messieurs rapportant l'avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
la réponse de monsieur le rapporteur est
très précise et parfaite d'ailleurs je
constate que en la matière ce
l'existence de cette loi a été utile
pour un certain nombre de communes qui
ont pour certaines d'entre elles je
pourrais vous citer quelques exemples
pression ont rattrapé leur retard
monsieur le sénateur et je pense que
c'est une bonne chose donc nous allons
effectivement par m revenir en arrière
c'est pourquoi l'avis du gouvernement
est défavorable
merci madame le ministre monsieur
larcher j'aimerais bien que quand on est
dans une communauté de communes de moins
de cinquante mille habitants on est
exonéré et quand on est dans la logique
d'une communauté de communes de plus de
50 mille habitants on se verra appliquer
ce dispositif
où la logique monsieur le rapporteur
c'est de l'appliquer pour tous où la
logique c'est de prendre en compte la
réalité car on peut être une commune de
15 150 habitants dans une communauté de
communes et c'est la cohérence d'un
texte que nous avons voté de plus de
50000 habitants dans ces secteurs qui
ont une densité relativement élevé il ya
là me semble-t-il une inéquité dans le
développement du logement social auquel
vous ne répondez pas du tout chez
je vais mettre au voir l'amendement 123
rectifié bis présenté par notre collègue
gérard larcher qui a eu deux avis
défavorables à mâlain progression le
président larcher évoqué des problèmes
de transport nous les avons déjà évoqué
en première lecture je voulais pas
revenir dessus puisque madame la
ministre n'en a pas tenu compte
mais nous avons des petites communes
dans lesquelles les gens ne veulent pas
s'installer dans lesquelles les
bailleurs sociaux ne veulent pas
construire parce qu'il n'y a pas de
transport est ce que vous allez un jour
réussir à comprendre de dire qu'on est
en agglomération parisienne c'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut pas une heure et
demie à deux heures pour aller
travailler et que le jeu des personnes
ne veulent pas aller s'installer dans
ces communes et parce qu'il n'y a pas de
moyen de transport
et c'est pas en arrêtant et je ne parle
même pas du super métro qui se construit
à d'autres communes qui ne sont même pas
dans cette circonscription est dans ces
endroits là et bien vous n'arriverez
jamais à mettre des personnes et en même
temps vous imposer ces communes qui de
toute façon ne peuvent rien faire elles
sont trop petites pour pouvoir
construire et elles n'auront jamais de
transport parce que justement il n'y a
pas suffisamment d'habitants et elles ne
peuvent pas aller plus loin
merci madame progression monsieur le
président oui monsieur larcher
indépendamment du respect que j'ai pour
vous il me l'impro cassia je n'arrive
pas à comprendre
à moins que la pentecôte de juin 2012
vous êtes touché qu'en dix ans ces
arguments vous les ayez pas employer
concernant les transports
parce que la loi sru monsieur larcher
les dates bien comme l'a dit le
rapporteur de 2000 vous avez eu 12 ans
pourra pour corriger éventuellement
comment se fait-il que c'est simplement
aujourd'hui que vous posez ces problèmes
de zones et oui c'est ça c'est trop
facile vous n'aviez qu'à changer la loi
et et non pas ici aujourd'hui
c'est à dire mais c'est d'allier la
présidente
la présidente ministre mes chers
collègues
l'amendement du président larcher pointe
du doigt l'une des faiblesses majeures
de ce texte comme d'ailleurs celui du
texte précédent
c'est qu'ils traitent la région
ile-de-france comme le limousin la seine
saint denis comme la creuse et que vous
ne prenez pas en compte les
particularités et depuis la loi
précédente et notamment région ile de
france les choses ont largement évolué
mes chers collègues
on essaye de ne plus raisonner de la
même manière et c'est d'ailleurs la
région et votre majorité qui luttent et
avec justesse contre l'étalement urbain
notamment à cause des problèmes de
transport et pour autant vous n'en tirez
pas de conclusions ni en termes de
gouvernance en matière de logement on
voit les difficultés dans lesquelles se
trouvent cette région et le syndicat
paris métropole qui a encore été
incapables qui a encore été incapables
de se mettre d'accord récemment sur une
gouvernance pas seulement en matière de
logement mais de manière plus générale
tout cela pour dire mes chers collègues
que la région ile de france que ce soit
en matière de logement en matière de
transports ou dans bien d'autres
domaines devraient nécessite nécessite
des dispositifs particuliers avec un
système de gouvernance particuliers
or la faiblesse principale de votre
texte c'est qu'effectivement on parle de
la mixité sociale aux pavillons sous
bois en seine saint denis comme à guéret
dans la creuse et je vous assure que
c'est radicalement différent merci chers
collègues la parole est à madame létard
oui madame la présidente même la
ministre chers collègues juste en
résonance de l'amendement de gérard
larcher de ce que vient de dire notre
collègue philippe dallier dire que tout
ça participe de l'esprit que nous
évoquons les uns et les autres sur la
nécessité d'avoir des règles nationales
ambitieuses en matière de loi sru
l'article 55 on va pas y revenir mais on
a peut-être possibilité d'essayer de
faire se conjuguent et des spécificités
territoriales des collectivités que sont
les agglos les établissements publics de
coopération intercommunale qui
travaillent dans la dentelle avec chacun
des maires
pour justement tenir compte de ces
adaptations une commune n'est pas
l'autre il y à des enjeux de transport
en commun ça a été dit et donc faisons
en sorte tout temps soyons ambitieux et
bien de ne pas les oublier ses
spécificités de ne pas oublier qu'il ya
des outils il ya des programmes locaux
de l'habitat et qu'on leur donne on
earth détricote la capacité justement à
faire de la dentelle encore ce temps au
travers d'un texte qui est trop cadré à
une échelle qui ne correspond pas à ses
spécificités et je voulais juste dire
parce que j'ai entendu parler de
transport collectif et deux du
gouvernement précédent qui aurait
peut-être dû s'investir plus je rappelle
juste que jean louis borloo a porté deux
appels à projets successifs pour
accompagner le financement de transport
collectif en site propre avec une
priorité donnée d'ailleurs au site en
russe à heroes sites prioritaires et que
nous attendons avec impatience le futur
appel à projets du gouvernement actuel
sur ce même sujet
merci madame létard monsieur dit la
merci mme la présidente
ce débat ressemble j'allais presque dire
furieusement à celui qui a précédé le
vote de la loi en 2000 et moi je trouve
que à force de te montrer les
particularités qui chacune d'entre elles
disent n'en faut pas faire de logement
social premièrement la particularité
doit être prise en compte la
particularité peut et doit être prise en
compte par le préfet deuxièmement
deuxièmement il faut que vraiment
j'essaye de le faire depuis le début on
se mette dans la tête que le logement
social c'est pas quelque chose de mal
qu'on doit nous imposer le logement
social c'est quelque chose de positif
il ya des tas il ya des tas de familles
qui vont bénéficier dans n'importe
quelle ville qu'il se soit l'île de
france la grande couronne où la petite
couronne qui vont pouvoir bénéficier de
logement social quand les enfants des
cohabitent quand on prend pas la tête
donc arrêtons de dire que le logement
social il faut essayer de s'en exonérer
c'est au contraire une richesse le
logement social c'est une richesse pour
toutes les communes
merci monsieur ghislain la parole est à
madame galli mais pour aller dans le
même sens que mon collègue pour dire que
j'ai donné un exemple qui marseille 80 %
des marseillais sont éligibles au
logement social
ça veut dire que c'est 80% de
marseillais n'auraient pas droit
aujourd'hui à l'accession au logement
social dans mes choix qu'il faut faire
attention sur les termes que vous
utilisez non mais de aujourd'hui de
ventre et le logement social comme
quelque chose est en négatif c'est une
erreur parce que d'abord vous serez tous
obligés dans vos communes pour pouvoir
loger tout simplement les enfants de vos
administrés les neveux et nièces les
voisins de vos administrés d'avoir un
moment la possibilité d'avoir du
logement social et donc c'est aussi dans
toutes les communes de france et moi je
le dis en tout cas pour ce qui est
marseille 80 % des marseillais sont
éligibles au logement social
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait leur dire que
non on doit pas construire alors je
crois qu'il faut un moment aussi être un
peu plus pragmatique et surtout un peu
plus sérieux merci chers collègues je
vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 123 rectifié vis présenté
par notre collègue larcher je rappelle
qu'il y à 2 l'avis défavorable qui pour
mercy qui est contre merci abstentions
la maman n'est pas adopté les gens vient
le moment 125 qui présenté par monsieur
ray charles
oui madame la présidente il s'agit ici
d'un amendement de repli puisque les
précédents n'ont pas été adoptés comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire pour de
nombreuses communes il est totalement
impossible de rattraper le retard
accumulé en termes de construction de
logements sociaux
à moins de ne créer que des logements
sociaux je m'en réfère à ce que
j'appelais tout à l'heure et que je ne
répète pas ici la course à l'échalote
dès lors il est proposé d'appliquer un
quota votre quota de 25 % aux nouvelles
constructions et non à l'ensemble des
résidences principales et je voudrais
vraiment
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure en aucun cas sur ces bancs vous
avez d opposer des opposants au logement
social mais nous souhaitons même plus
que cela des amendements ont été
présentés visant à étendre l'obligation
de logement social à d'autres communes
que celles qui ont plus de 3500
habitants dans des agglomérations de
50000 pourquoi ne pas l'ouvrir à toutes
les communes de 3500 habitants
pourquoi avoir à être revenu sur le la
décision qui avait été prise en cet
instant sans fin et accepter en
commission mixte paritaire d'ouvrir du
logement social aux communes de 1500
pourquoi pourquoi le la difficulté ici
céline équité et l'impossibilité de
réaliser des logements sociaux dans des
communes qui n'en peuvent plus merci
messieurs les chars
j'ai demandé l'avis de notre rapporteur
oui avant de répondre je voudrais quand
même
rafraîchissez voit la mémoire quand le
groupe ump a dit qu était favorable à
une obligation pour les communes de 15
centres mais ses habitants
j'ai participé à la cnp et vos
représentants étaient farouchement
contre alors il faudra que vous ne leur
disent y est très clairement
cela étant dit pour revenir à
l'amendement que vous proposez il remet
en cause de l'esprit même de l'article
55 de la loi sru puisque on appliquerait
le pourcentage que sur les nouvelles
constructions dont il remet en cause en
totalité l'objet même de la loi
dans cet avis défavorable merci monsieur
le rapporteur madame la ministre votre
avis madame la ministre
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un parc de 25 %
de logements locatifs sociaux dans
chaque commune c'est ça l'objectif
l'objectif n'est pas de la construction
neuve parce que sinon on risque d'avoir
dans un temps donnant droit à une
stabilité quasi définitive du nombre de
logements locatifs sociaux donc il faut
favoriser la mutation du parquet c'est
pourquoi je suis défavorable à cet
amendement
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance
suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par
trois avec comme invitée ce soir la
ministre de la santé et des affaires
sociales marisol touraine bonne fin de
journée à tous